le vent à Bordeaux est-il en voie de
disparition ces vignes vont bientôt être
arrachées par l'état car dans le
Bordelais les petits producteurs de vin
rouge traversent une grave crise entre
redressement judiciaire et vente en
chute libre les vignerons sont en burn
out Bastien Mercier par exemple les
viticulteurs et maire de caméra en
Gironde dans quelques mois la moitié de
son domaine soit près de 20 hectares de
raisin sera arraché il n'a pas le choix
son entreprise a été placé en
redressement judiciaire début 2023 il y
a quelques années il a créé un collectif
vitres 33 qui réunit 300 vignerons à
bout de souffle afin de trouver une
solution pour réduire la surproduction
de vin rouge en fait le collectif
proposait une indemnisation de 10000
euros par hectare arraché le but inciter
les vignerons à arracher près de 15000
hectares sur les 50000 de rouge en
Gironde mais coup de massue pour les
vignerons l'État a proposé seulement
6000 euros par hectares des racines le 5
juin dernier et pour les vignerons qui
ne veulent pas se reconvertir ils
doivent laisser le terrain en jachère
pendant 20 ans cela fait des années que
la filière du vin rouge de Bordeaux
souffre beaucoup en France à
consommation est en baisse continue les
gens veulent des alcools plus fun qui
peuvent se boire avec des burgers et des
sushisky Stéphanie pér chercheurs en
économie à Bordeaux sciences agro le vin
rouge de Bordeaux serait devenu vieux
jeu d'autres facteurs ont aggravé cette
crise l'épidémie de covid-19 d'abord
avec la fermeture du marché chinois mais
aussi les conflits commerciaux avec les
États-Unis de Donald Trump qui ont fait
réduire les exportations sans parler du
mildiou ce champignon qui détruit les
récoltes et touche actuellement plus de
90 % du vignoble dans le département
résultat un viticulteur sur deux
voudraient arrêter d'après le collectif
depuis le début de cette crise 5
vignerons ce serait donné la mort et
près de 1320 domaines viticoles soient
35 000 hectares se disent en grande
difficulté